- How does that make you feel?
- How does it make me feel?
Used.
- I'm not in your top 10.
I had 200 yards
against the Rams.
Is that changing?
- Uh, well, it could,
you know, it could change.
- We could buy so many jet skis,
Le'Veon
if you win the Super Bowl.
♪♪♪
- Welcome again
to "Simms & Lefkoe."
Our hands are out
because it's happened.
You messed up my tattoo.
The Saints are now
the No. 1 seed in the NFC,
Simms.
Thanks a lot!
I gotta go get it changed.
- Well, you got the teams right,
OK?
Gotta write, you know,
put a two above the one.
- Oh, thanks, man.
I appreciate—
- You'll deal with it.
- Is that how it's gonna be?
Saints definitely No. 1?
It looks like they got
home-field advantage now.
- The Saints are awesome.
No, I'm not gonna anoint them
king of the NFC yet.
- OK.
- They still have to play
the Eagles, the Steelers,
the Panthers twice, OK?
- Yep.
- And, hey, as awesome
as that win was—
- Yeah.
- Don't get me wrong
I still think the Rams
are the most dangerous team
in the NFC.
- The AFC makes sense to me.
- Right.
- Patriots, Chiefs,
Chargers, Steelers
seem like the cream of the crop.
- With ya.
- The NFC,
there was those top two teams
Saints and Rams.
- Right.
- And then what other teams
scare you?
- Well, I mean, the Carolina Panthers—
- Well, duh.
- Yeah, I know, but they
deserve some respect.
I don't feel like they're getting
it on a national level.
- Any surprises?
- If you made me go
who's the next best team
in the NFC—
- Who you pickin'?
- Buckle your seatbelt, OK?
Buckle that.
Ooh.
I still like
the Philadelphia Eagles.
- Uh. Seatbelt's on.
- Philadelphia Eagles.
I have come away watching
Philadelphia film on every week
even in their four losses,
going
"They were the better team
on the field."
They've messed up
some situational play.
They had Nick Foles early
when they lost
to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers—
- Sure.
- And Fitzmagic was working.
- Tennessee, Minnesota...
- Exactly right.
I mean, you just look at it—
Carolina.
They dominate the whole game—
- 17-nothing.
- Except the last
two or three drives, right
where they did some dumb stuff.
- Wow.
- I think with Wentz having
Golden Tate in the fold now—
- Yeah.
- And the defense being better
I would still say
watch out for the Eagles.
- I'll tattoo them on right now.
- Oh, I know you would!
Easy. You might put that on your neck.
[Cellphone ringing]
- Oh, hold on.
Someone put something
under this cushion.
- That's weird.
- Cuz I definitely didn't.
- Sure.
- Oh, you've gotta
be kidding me.
- Oh my gosh.
- Hold on.
Hey.
No.
He's right here.
Yeah.
It's for you, pal.
- Yeah, it's my
2001 college phone.
This is great.
- Yeah.
- Hello?
- Hey, Simmsy, what up?
Mikey T down
here in New Orleans.
- Oh.
- How 'bout that touchdown, pal?
- Oh, hello, Michael Thomas.
Yes, it's great
to hear from you.
You played awesome on Sunday.
It was a phenomenal performance.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Anyway,
let's get down to brass tacks.
I'm not in your top 10.
I had 200 yards
against the Rams.
Is that changing?
- Uh, well
it could,
you know, it could change.
- Uh, uh, uh!
- You were awesome.
- Put me in the top 10, stutterer.
- Yes, I am stuttering.
I know I'm kinda dumb and
a little crazy at times, but
hey, you got
an awesome quarterback.
You got one of the best
play-callers
in the history of the sport.
- You think Brandin Cooks
is better than me?
- OK. I—I might be wrong.
[Line beeping]
I might have to re-evaluate
that.
You might have to crack
the top 10.
Hey, I gotta go.
I got another call, sorry.
Hello?
- Simmba, what up?
AFC Offensive Player
of the Month.
That's right.
The one, the only
James Conner.
Not a top-five running back
according to you, pal.
- Ah, OK.
I'm—
James, you're really good, man.
You're awesome.
I mean, I don't know
what to say.
Yeah, I'm not gonna put you
in the top five in the NFL yet.
There's some freaky guys—
- Most touchdowns
for the Steelers
in the first eight games
since 1950!
- OK, stats don't tell it all.
They don't tell the truth.
Ryan Fitzpatrick is
the fifth-rated quarterback
in football, man.
I don't know what to tell you.
You're the fourth-best player
on your own offense.
I can't put you in the top five
running backs in the league.
[Line beeping]
I gotta go, man.
Steelers, go Steelers.
Like ya.
Hello?
- Christopher.
- Holy crap.
- Hi. It's Tom.
- Hello, Tom.
- Always a pleasure
to hear your voice.
- Hello, oh great GOAT one,
how are you?
- How are you?
How are the children?
- They're good. Thank you, Tom.
- Great.
Um, someone told me,
and it's a little upsetting
but you still have me
behind Rodgers
and I just beat him
and I know you wouldn't
really do that.
- I—well, hey, first of all,
it's a team sport, Tom
and you're awesome, man.
- Thanks, man.
- I mean, you're one
of the greatest of all time.
You're just not better
than Rodgers, but—
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
- Yeah, no, you're not.
Sorry. Just be quiet.
I'm talking, OK?
And then the other thing, too,
is you're 41
and I still have you as
one of the five best
quarterbacks in the sport.
But, I mean,
you also have awesome players
and coaches around you.
I'm not tryin' to take
anything away from you, Tom.
You're still awesome.
I'm just tryin'
to keep it real, man.
- Chris, how many hugs
have we shared?
This is hurting my heart.
- We haven't shared
any hugs, sorry.
- Oh.
- We shared some
vegan ice cream once.
See ya.
- All right. That was great.
- Wow.
Thank you for that phone call.
- You shared vegan ice cream
with Tom Brady?
- Not really.
I just sounded cool.
- This is Jalen Ramsey
and you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
- Hello and welcome.
It's the Drs.
Simms and Lefkoe
and we're here with
our new patient, Landon Collins.
Landon is a shining star
of the New York Giants
franchise.
- Lan-don, I'm just curious.
- Mhmm?
- As you've gone
through this season
and people ask you
probing questions
how does it make you feel?
- Uh, they just
tryin' to make a story
out of the words
you were saying, you know.
Most people kinda twist it up
and get a story out of it.
- When you see your friend Odell
be classified with words
like "selfish" and "mean"
and "egotistical"
um, do you say anything to him?
Do you want to be
his therapist sometimes?
- Ah, nah, I don't wanna be
his therapist
cuz I know
there's a lot more in that head
than we all know.
- Ohh.
- But I'm there for him.
I'm always gonna be
a brother for him.
- Mm.
- I feel for him.
It's that the world
is against him.
- It must feel like that.
- Loyalty.
- Very loyal.
- Yeah, that's very good.
- Landon, tell us
about Saquon Barkley.
- [Laughing]
- Saquon?
- Yes.
Tell me about his quads
when you see them in spandex.
- [Laughing]
- I think they gonna knock
somebody out.
Honestly, I feel like
they gonna hurt somebody.
You can crush somebody's head
with them things.
What is it like watching
the greatest quarterback
in Giants history
have to go through
such a struggling year?
What's it been like for you guys
to have to deal
with those questions?
- Emotionally.
- Watching him go out there
each and every week
I expect greatness, you know?
I expect to see greatness
because that's what I'd watched
when I was growing up, you know.
And seeing that we havin'
a losing streak
and he's not gettin' the wins
and stuff like that, it's hard.
It's hard not for just him
and not for just the offense
hard for the whole team.
Honestly,
we sticking behind 10
because we know
he has it in him
he know how to win
so I think we can figure
it out together, yeah.
- Elitis.
- Elitis. Very much Elitis.
- Yeah, that's right.
- He suffers from the most severe kind of Elitis.
- I wanna say that
for you to lay on this couch
and to do this
you have vaunted yourself
into Simms and Lefkoe's—
- Hall of Fame.
- Top five Hall of Fame
favorite guests
for playing along
with this absolute nonsense.
- You got it.
- I didn't know they were gonna
to go there with you.
- I didn't know either.
- I didn't know we were
goin' there with you.
- All right.
Sit up, sit up, sit up.
I can't do this anymore.
I can't imagine being a New York
athlete with dozens of cameras
in your face after every game
and they're asking you guys
the same question.
- Mhmm.
- And nothing they want more
than for you to go,
"He ain't that good.
I'm tired of this guy."
I would love it if you guys
had a place to release it
to, like, let it all go.
- Mhmm.
- But you can't.
- No.
- And I wonder
what that's like as an athlete
where, like, you have a truth
and you can't speak that truth.
- All right, put it this way.
If you was to say that, correct?
- Yes.
- And I get traded and you
get traded, or you get cut
or you get put
into another team.
- Yeah.
- You think those guys
would trust you?
- Exactly. Yep.
- That's the thing.
So you don't even think
"How are the media
gonna twist my words?"
You go, "I need to go
and look at those guys
in the locker room."
- Each and every day.
- Hmm.
Have you ever been
in a locker room
where someone has said something
where you were like—
- I was one guy to say something
about the Eli Apple thing.
- Yeah.
- And so you learned a lot
from that experience.
- Correct.
- Man, what were the days
after you said that stuff,
for you, personally?
- For me, personally,
it was just constantly answering
the question
about it to the media.
Then, um, just,
my guys is like
"It was kinda
the right thing to do but not—
that's not the way
you handle that situation."
- Right.
It was that you realized
that afterwards
you were like,
"That was my truth
but the timing wasn't great"?
- Correct.
I kinda wanna ask an
opponent thing.
- Better yet,
who's the best player
you've had to play
against in general?
Who would you
give that crown to?
- Aaron Rodgers.
- Thank you.
- Oh, Aaron Rodgers.
- You are the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen.
- Please talk about that.
- Aaron?
- Yes.
- Oh, man.
He's phenomenal.
I remember—I could
tell you one play.
We had a practice squad guy
lined up on 17, right?
- Right.
- So I'm disguising them
kind of down towards the box
but I'm actually going back.
So, for some reason,
I'm in this stance
and I'm never in this stance.
A-Rod looked at me and smiled
and kinda gave,
like, a lil' giggle.
And then did something
with his hand to 17.
I knew it was a signal to 17.
I looked at 17, I looked
at my guy that's covering him.
I said, "S--t."
As soon as he said "Hut"
I tried to run
before he said "Hut."
He already said it.
I'm already out of leverage.
Touchdown to 17 over my guy.
- Man.
- So just the mindset,
his preparation for the game
his ability to move out
of the pocket
and throw off his back foot.
You never see any
quarterbacks here
besides, I think, Brett Favre
throw off his back foot
like he does.
- Right, right.
- And he's just a great guy.
- Man, he giggles,
and your heart just sinks.
- Cuz I already knew
what he was doing.
I already knew.
- "There's something
that I don't know," yeah.
- Appreciate you, man.
- You got it. No doubt.
- Le'Veon, time to wake up.
Time to go to
the Steelers facility today.
It's time to finally check in
and be a good teammate.
- Or we could never go back
and watch them
suffer into the ground!
- It's time to go in
and apologize to your teammates
tell them how much
you missed football.
- You heard
what they said about you
those offensive linemen.
How many touchdowns
have they scored?
James Conner,
you should shave his head
when you get to camp.
- Think big-picture, Le'Veon.
- So then what's
the bigger plan, angel?
- You can be a part of a winner.
This team can win
the Super Bowl, Le'Veon.
And you know what that means?
More dollars.
- We could buy so many jet skis,
Le'Veon
if you win the Super Bowl.
- Mutual funds with the extra
money, Le'Veon.
Mutual funds.
- How many touchdowns
do you think you're going
to catch this season?
- Let's go at nine.
- Ohhh.
- Wow.
- I am gonna take the under.
If it goes over, nine or over
I will donate $1,000
to the Wimberly's
and their help
for the youth in Cambodia.
- Sounds good. Take him down!
- It's a bet.
- How many interceptions
do you think
you're gonna have this season?
- I'm gonna go with seven.
- I'm gonna say
that you go over
seven interceptions
this year.
If I'm wrong
I'm going to donate $1,000
to the Fam 1st charity.
- I'll take that bet.
- How many completed passes
do you think you will have
this season?
- I mean, the line's
gotta be two.
It's gotta be just over
average, and then, uh...
- So two?
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna take the under.
- OK.
- If you get over two
I will donate $1,000
to the Special Olympics
in your name.
- Yeah!
- We got it right there, man.
- And it's a Lefkoe Lock!
- So those were our bets
before the season
and let's see where they stand.
I took the under
on nine receiving touchdowns
for Cooper Kupp.
He's at six.
- Damn.
And he missed a game or two.
You're in trouble.
Sorry.
- He did miss a game or two.
Every time I turn on the game
he's runnin' down the sidelines!
- Yeah.
- Cooper, I'm rootin'
against you, man.
- Yeah, I'm not.
- I'm sorry.
- Yeah, he's not.
- Take Lefkoe's money.
- Marcus Peters
I said he would have over
seven interceptions—
- What were you thinking?
- Is there any chance he can get
six in the second half of the year?
- Absolutely not.
Absolutely not, sorry.
- Johnny Hekker,
I said he would get under two.
He's at one right now.
- Oh.
- This is the one that I got
my fingers crossed for.
Keep running 'em, Sean McVay.
- Fassel and McVay are gonna have
a few more tricks for him
before the season's out.
- I know.
- Yeah, you're in trouble there.
- So you think I lose all three?
- I do.
- Now, Marcus Peters, though
everyone has been
kinda baggin' on him
especially after
that Michael Thomas catch.
- Sure.
- And you kinda—
you don't think that's accurate.
- No.
I think Marcus Peters
did a lotta good things.
Listen, Michael Thomas is good.
He's a huge receiver.
He made some unbelievable
contested catches
and this will be
my big point, Lefkoe.
Yeah, he messed up
on the big touchdown play.
There's no doubt about that
but what Marcus Peters was asked
to do in that football game
there's only a few corners
in football
that you would even ask
or put in that situation.
Yeah, it wasn't his best
but it wasn't as horrible
as everybody in the world
is trying to make it out to be.
- If you were to compare me
to a quarterback
in terms of my betting,
who would I be?
- Oh, that's an easy one.
- Carson Wentz?
- Exactly not, no.
- Oh.
- Hello, Nathan Peterman
of betting.
Good to see you.
Oh, it's another pick-six!
- I'm tired of this
Nathan Peterman slander
and I just wanna say,
Nate, I salute you.
- He does. Not me.
- Hey, Nathan Peterman.
You may not be super good at football,
but that's not the point.
You, my friend,
are providing a service
more honorable than winning.
Your critics see you
relentlessly
giving it away
to the other team.
But not me.
I see you taking one
for the team.
Your O-line stinks.
Your receiving corps
is the worst in football.
And Shady McCoy is a
shadow of himself.
This is all a recipe
for failure
and you are failing—
spectacularly.
Bills Mafia
wants to treat you
like a folding table.
[Laughing]
Why are you doing this?
Why, because you're the man, Nate.
You're the Peter-man.
And you're falling
on that grenade so hard
so Josh Allen takes
absolutely no shrapnel.
In a city that loves wings, Nate,
you are the ultimate wingman.
And that's is pretty cool.
- Two-week losing streak
on "Somebody & Lefkoe"?
I will not stand for it.
First "The Dragon"
and then Grace?
We need to cut this short
and there's one man that I know
that's good with the scissors
Boris the Barber.
- We are here,
Little Tony, Igor Be Good.
This is my man, Boris
and Thursday night,
this is how this works.
I got $250 of
Bleacher Report's money.
I'm gonna put it on this game.
Panthers at Steelers
Steelers are favored by four.
What do you know
about these teams?
- Well, I watched a few games
here and there
and I know Steelers
are pretty good.
- Yeah? Panthers?
- Panthers, not much.
You're not really hearing
much about them.
- They have Cam Newton.
They run the ball really well.
It's in Pittsburgh.
The Steelers are favored by four.
I wanna split money with you,
Boris.
I wanna cut it like you
just cut my hair.
Who you pickin'?
- Panthers.
- And the Boris bet is official.
Lefkoe Lock, Boris Bet.
Lefkoe Lock.
- You got it.
- Boris Bet.
Finally, we're getting a good
"Thursday Night Football" game
and I'm hopin' Boris the Barber
calls this one.
He's takin' the Panthers
plus-four in Pittsburgh.
- Ooh, I likey.
- Do you likey?
- I—
- How likey do you likey?
- Man, plus-four.
Ooh, this is a great game.
I don't like "Thursday Night
Football," first of all.
I just wanna state that.
They need to just have "Thursday
Night Football" after bye week
so we can see
these teams at their best.
They're not at their best
on a Thursday night.
- No.
- I'm gonna take
Carolina Panthers.
- You feelin' it?
- Yeah, I—
I mean, I'm not gonna say
they're gonna win outright
- But that's too much.
- But I think they keep it
within four, yes.
- A few weeks ago
when the Steelers lost
to the Ravens the first time
everyone was calling out
Mike Tomlin
saying they'd lost the culture
fights with Antonio Brown,
Big Ben
what's up with Le'Veon
and you believe,
after four straight wins
the nation owes Mike Tomlin
an apology?
- I do. I mean, come on.
And thank you for bringing it up
because we gotta go there.
Yeah, if we're all gonna
crap on Mike Tomlin
when things go bad
and blame him and
"Oh, he set a bad culture"
and, you know,
"The team's too renegade
and he has no control"
then when things go positively
we have to take it back
and all self-scout.
- Yes.
- OK?
And go, "Damn, well
he's obviously fixed things
in the locker room.
Their defense
has been playing better."
He was a defensive coordinator.
I've been around him.
- Yeah.
- So he's fixed that part
of the team.
- Sure.
- And the WiFi
between Ben and Antonio Brown
is working phenomenal.
- Yeah.
- So way to go, Mike T.
Keep shuttin' up
all those haters.
- Yes. Don't just give credit
to the coaches
that seemingly scheme.
Mike Tomlin is more
than just a rah-rah guy.
- Yes.
- Tomlin, way to do it.
- For Simms.
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And we will holla, holla,
holla atcha later.
Enjoy the games.
♪♪♪
- This dude is the same one
that had you pooping
in your pants for attention
when you were six.
Don't listen to the angel.
He's a scumbag.
- If pooping in your pants
is cool
then I'm Miles Davis.
Nobody?
Anybody?